physically do you feel like you could go
play a game on sunday
oh i think we're going to keep uh
keep working we got a couple more days
to figure out we're going to do what's
what's smart for
um for myself and the team
but i hope so i hope i can go help him
contribute to a win some somehow some
way
[Music]
jaylen ramsey newest member of the la
rams and you know you still have to sell
that you had a back injury even after
you've been traded and you're back is
magically cured the rams are helping him
out they listed him yesterday is fully
participating in practice despite the
back injury there's no back injury i'm
not sure there ever was a back injury at
a minimum it was grossly embellished but
it worked he got what he wanted he's now
with the rams they go to atlanta and
they need him big cat they got julio
jones and calvin ridley i think he plays
and i think the rams win this one easily
yeah i think the rams win this one
easily as well it's a get right game for
the rams and i think jared goff's gonna
have a really nice day the the falcons
don't play defense they don't play
defense like i actually don't think they
even have defensive meetings during the
week if you watched them play against
the cardinals last week there were
stretches where it was just green grass
everywhere so this is a get right game
and jaylen ramsey i mean think about
this you you could make the case
that the rams now have
two top five guys at least two guys that
are maybe at the top of their position
on defense and so you know especially
the way they complement each other where
jaylen ramsey can kind of eliminate the
best guy on the other side of the ball
and aaron donald can can get to the
quarterback like that's that's going to
be nice for the for the rams if they can
figure it out on offense
i'm going to be curious to see how they
use them will they put them on julio
jones all the time will they put them on
calvin ridley and double julio jones
will they just put him on one side of
the field and just assume that the ball
is never going to that side of the field
whoever lines up over there so to be
interesting to see how he's used this
week and beyond because they may use him
differently week in and week out we'll
see but the other thing on the falcons
dan quinn he's got two games left rams
and seahawks at home if he loses both of
those by week comes next and because dan
quinn made himself the defensive
coordinator so he can't fire his
defensive coordinator and blame it all
on him it's dan quinn so i think the
train's pulling into the station there
all right raiders at lambeau field to
take on the green bay packers two weeks
for john gruden to get ready go back to
the place where his his coaching career
as an nfl coach got started 92-94 he was
a member of that that mike holmgren
staff
and they have an opening now with
patrick mahomes injured if he misses
some time raiders at three and two they
beat the bears you saw what they can do
can they do it at lambeau field with the
packers on a short week feeling like
they stole one on monday night from the
lions yeah you know i i got caught with
my pants down thinking the raiders were
the raiders of last year i think this
team has is pretty talented and i i do
think that they have some nice things
they can they can do they have a little
bit of an identity their offensive line
a bunch of monsters so they can run the
ball and that's really what it you know
when you're building a team up like this
if you can do one thing pretty well
it makes everything else a little bit
easier because you go into the game
saying this is our identity this is what
we want to do and i think the packers
defense has shown to be at times a lot
in the you know we all got really
excited or i didn't get excited but
people got excited that the packers
finally have a defense i don't know if
it's as good as everyone's making out to
be
i would if i had to go with a straight
up pick it's probably packers but i
think the raiders will will stay within
i think it's a six point spread right
now
sources close to me tell me that the
line moved dramatically in the raiders
direction this week so somebody knows
that the raiders aren't nearly as as bad
as we would think and i think a lot of
that the raiders of last year still
hovers over how people look at this team
look look at what they did at indy
and against the bears
after starting off one and two they have
figured something out with josh jacobs
just run the ball run the ball run the
ball and set up some play action passes
and and trust your defense to be able to
slow down an offense a big hat all the
receivers are injured for the packers
devante adams is still out marquez
valdez scantling out jerome allison out
jimmy graham has an ankle injury and pat
and uh
aaron rodgers still has a need that's
limiting him in practice so i i think i
think they're going to win this one
straight up i really do oh wow yeah i
mean that's a nice pick by you um but
the raiders they're they are like it was
last year and then it was that second
quarter against the chiefs that is where
the perception comes from because
remember the raiders actually played the
chiefs well except for that second
quarter when patrick mahomes went
absolutely insane on him and was scoring
on every single play
they did get dismantled week three at
minnesota somehow i don't know how it
happened but it did happen especially
given how they've played since then
well speaking of kirk cousins he heads
to detroit this is one of those games
where
they probably shouldn't win right even
though they're a slight favorite which
is weird to me big spot on the road
division rival their third road game
against an nfc north team so far this
year
can kirk cousins and an offense that has
generated 937 yards over the last two
games continue against alliance team
that has got to be extremely salty after
what happened on monday night yeah i i
like the lions here because it is one of
those things where i think they believe
in matt patricia now i think the bounce
back will be nice from a game they
should have had in green bay which would
have kind of changed the scope of the
nfc north as it sits right now the
reason why the vikings are favored here
is i don't know how the lions are going
to run the football so this is a matt
stafford game will matt stafford be able
to win this game with his arm and i mean
i think it's gonna be a very ugly tight
game i think it's going to be low
scoring and i'll take the lions but i
you you're so down on kirk cousins i
think kirk cousins great i think they
should give him a contract extension he
won that big game
against yeah okay uh look i i know how
this season's gonna go and i have it
mapped out already seven and seven going
into the last two games a monday night
game against the packers a game against
your bears that following sunday they
don't win the
they don't win maybe both uh they
definitely don't win both games and they
won't be in the playoffs but but this is
one of the games that will prove my
theory wrong because i have them losing
at detroit we'll see if they can pull it
off and i have to wear kirk cousins
jersey next thursday apparently if the
if the vikings win i i did not specify
which kirk cousins jersey though i'm
going to find a washington kirk cousins
jersey because next thursday by the way
washington at minnesota the kirk cousins
revenge game texans at the colts round
one of the afc south championship in
large part because the titans and the
jaguars are both two and four
i tell you what the call we forgot about
the colts because they they were off
last week but the last time we saw them
they were beating the chiefs in
arrowhead and the last time we saw the
texans they were beating the chiefs in
arrowhead texans traditionally have
struggled in indy this could be a very
very good game i like the colts by a
little bit
uh but i could see it go either way yeah
i like the colts too and you're right we
totally forgot about them because that
bye week came after that big win against
kansas city when there are 11 point
underdogs on sunday night football and
they did better against the chiefs than
the texans did last week yet somehow we
we were like oh the texans are that much
better than the cults i think these two
teams are pretty even and i would take
the colts off a buy
and i i am super impressed with frank
reich as a head coach and i think that
everything they've done this year they
need more credit for losing andrew luck
right before the season starts and
sitting here three and two and if they
win this game they'd be four and two and
uh i don't know the standings but i
would assume yeah no they would be in
first place in the afc south who would
have thought that halfway through
october after losing uh andrew luck so i
like what the colts are doing and they
need a lot of credit and i'll take the
colts
and this is one of those in my mind home
team gets the edge if they were playing
in houston i probably would take the
texans and deshaun watson has been
phenomenal and he may be one of the
leading candidates now and he is one of
the leading candidates for mvp if
patrick mahomes is out for an extended
stretch if he's hampered when he returns
it may come down to deshaun watson and
russell wilson all right 49ers heading
to washington now ordinarily i would say
this is a potential correction game for
the 49ers but kyle shanahan is still so
mad about his time in washington and
what they did to him and what they did
to his dad mike shanahan and he made the
comment earlier this week about
washington
i think that the 49ers are going to
destroy washington on sunday i agree
with you and on top of that when you
have a win or sorry the redskins won
last week when you have a team one in
five
going against a team like the 49ers i
think the the the one and five team can
hang if it's if it's played through the
air they can't hang when's when it's run
the ball down your throat because if we
know anything about the nfl when when
guys are out there and they got nothing
to play for and they're just getting
bodied and manhandled the 49ers are
going to take it to him and going to
take it to him early and often
and this may be a game too where if they
get a big lead it's a chance for kyle
shanahan to kind of you know go a little
deeper into the playbook try to show
some different looks to give future
opponents things to think about it's
almost like a mid-season preseason game
where you can you can lay the foundation
for what you might or might not be doing
later in the year and you know it
becomes cat and mouse if they're toying
with the the washington defense the way
that i think they will and i think it's
gonna be ugly i'm shocked that the line
is only nine and a half points yep yep i
agree take the take the uh niners easy i
i believe in the niners now i'm a full
believer in the 49ers
well you're not allowed to be you know
like richard sherman says if you didn't
believe in the 49ers before the season
you're not allowed to change your mind
now you have to continue to assume that
they're not going to be very good even
though they're demonstrating to us week
in and week out that they're great
that's richard sherman's rule not mine
richard sherman also said that baker
mayfield disrespected him and didn't
shake his hand and then we saw a billion
angles of bakery shaking his hands so
i'm not taking what sherman says he's
ready to go you know i mean there's
there's maybe a couple different things
terminology wise
that
that he's got to get used to and and he
said he'd let me know by uh
friday he's ready to go the whole thing
and i said well just lie to me and tell
me that you are and we'll just go play
that's kenny powers who retired from
baseball to become a football coach
actually wink martindale the defensive
coordinator of the baltimore ravens they
have marcus peters that was the first
domino that got everyone's attention
about a jalen ramsey trade to the rams
peter's in baltimore and they need him
they need help in the secondary they've
had a lot of injuries i assume he's
going to play one of the best games of
the day baltimore ravens at the seattle
seahawks a couple of mvp candidates in
russell wilson and lamar jackson
this one you know the defenses aren't
great the offenses are this could become
uh
an interesting back and forth maybe high
scoring type of a game big cat mike
florio just gave you his mortal locket
see over uh the ravens the ravens are a
fraudulent team until they win one of
these next two games i've i've laid it
out for ravens fans i've had a back and
forth this week i
i like lamar jackson i think their
defense is suspect if they win
at seattle or next week against the
patriots i will officially start taking
the ravens for real until that happens
i'm putting the fraud tag on them
yeah you know what and i don't disagree
with that take because
you look at what they've done okay they
blew out the dolphins big deal they beat
the cardinals by six they just beat the
bengals by six they lost at home to the
browns and that win over the chiefs in
hindsight not or not win over the chiefs
that lost to the chiefs in hindsight
where it looked kind of close but it
really wasn't that's less impressive now
that the chiefs have lost two games at
home to the colts and the texans so i
think i'm i'm with you on this although
they've got a two-game lead in the afc
north i don't think they're as good as
the hype would suggest because we're
caught up in lamar jackson and he is
playing great but the other concern is
at some point he's going to get injured
you can't take all those hits
and not at some point be unable to get
up it's just basic physics it's going to
happen aaron rodgers told lamar jackson
back in the preseason slide we see
rogers always do it we never see lamar
jackson do it and it's almost like rg3
when he was a rookie just took the hits
took the hits took the hits until
against the ravens he took the hit that
ultimately uh derailed his career big
cat yeah i mean lamar jackson doesn't
get hit like rg3 did and he's a little
bit better with his body but i just i i
still believe in the pittsburgh steelers
i i really do i think the steelers i
think they play the colts and the
dolphins coming up the ravens have the
the patriots and the seahawks this could
be four and four pretty quickly this
could be four and four you're not upset
i thought you'd be upset with the
steelers because they're sending you
guys cod just back to the bench that's
okay duck's fine duck will duck will be
ready for uh whenever he needs to come
back in but i think the steelers defense
is kind of rounding into form and they
have a little bit of a nobody believes
in us so i think that's going to be the
race in the afc north and listen if the
if the ravens win on sunday i will
absolutely put my hand up and say i was
wrong i'm taking this team for real i
think they're better than i gave him
credit for but i have to see it i have
to see it against a real a good opponent
a playoff caliber opponent before i
really believe it with baltimore
yeah i like the seahawks in this one i
don't think the ravens are going to pull
it off eagles cowboys sunday night
football on nbc both are three and three
they both need this win badly who do you
like i love the eagles in this game i
think the oh boys i love the eagles in
this game i think the cowboys are
teetering on the edge here mike and
their offensive line is banged up i
don't know i think they're gonna have a
couple starters out again mark cooper
might not play
i think the the cowboys are right on
that line where it's like is this going
to go south on us and the eagles are a
team that bounces back well they got
embarrassed by the vikings got
embarrassed by kirk cousins i trust doug
peterson in this game more than jason
garrett i think the eagles are going to
win this game
but see last year the cowboys were three
and five going into a sunday night game
at philadelphia and the sta the same
storm clouds were gathering over jason
garrett there was talk that if they got
blown out he was going to be fired then
they won seven of the last eight games
and it began with that win at
philadelphia that's what swayed me to
think at home the cowboys can pull this
one off uh i think you know the eagles
have injury issues as well and until
they get to sean jackson back that
offense isn't going to be everything
that it can be
that there may be some consternation in
the locker room that they didn't make a
more aggressive play for jaylen ramsey i
just think that the the cowboys
find a way despite jason garrett who may
not be there next year but at least
he'll be there next week because i think
they're going to get right and get to
four and three that doesn't mean they're
gonna win the division and i think only
one team out of the nfc east is going to
the playoffs so they're going to keep
battling week in and week out but i
think for now it's going to be the
cowboys all right we got to get to your
team the chicago bears back after a bye
week that ugly loss to the raiders
13-play 97-yard drive that was decisive
against the defense that was supposedly
as good as the 85 bears income the
saints at five and one but they are
banged up big cat i like your team in
this one i think the saints are too
injured offensively and i think the
bears are going to be too upset over
what happened in london and they could
be back at the scene of that that
destruction of the vikings i think
they're going to be fine against the
saints yeah i think the bear's going to
win this game uh it's one of those ones
where the saints don't need the game the
bears do and that usually goes the way
the team that needs the game in the nfl
i think it's gonna be an ugly game
though mike i don't see the bears
offense doing much against a very good
underrated saints defense and vice versa
i don't know if the saints have any
weapons to beat the uh bears defense
with some of the injuries they have on
the offensive side of the ball so i'm
thinking a low scoring game but the
bears are gonna take the approach they
did in denver week two where they're
just gonna win any way possible it
doesn't matter about style points it
doesn't matter about throwing down field
with mitch trubisky it's all about
getting a win getting to four and two
and then reassessing going forward
yeah and they're going to have a fight
week in and week out to get a playoff
berth this year because they're already
chasing the packers they lost to them at
home
and there are so many good second place
teams in the nfc those wild card births
are going to be hard to come by
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports